hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the full
chess Classic Tournament it's a
classical tournament featuring 10 very
strong Grand Masters played in the St
Louis chess club and here we have a game
I believe from round eight um between
the uh well the highest rated Ukrainian
Grand Master Ilia niznik ever since uh
was dropped a few points now niznik is
some 15 I believe uh rating points high
rated and vasel evanchook and he's
facing Hans moken Neiman in almost 2700
player and this is a very very exciting
game features a very cool line of the
Sicilian Defense some 17 moves of known
Theory and then the position just opens
up which we all enjoy and before we get
to the game a lot of you have been
asking me what is up with the steinit
Saga I have been preparing it and I was
almost ready to launch it but then my
daughter got sick she was sick for about
a month and I just didn't find the time
to continue uh preparing The Saga I
don't want to rush it because once I I
start with the shiny Saga I want to have
at least one video of foreign
you know ready ready for every day maybe
even two videos so I will see if I will
be able to pull it off uh so I really
don't want to rush it once it's out it's
it's gonna be out and it's gonna be
going very smoothly and uh I'm guessing
it will be around 60 to 100 videos
depending on depending on you know which
which route I will take I'm still
deciding on whether to go beyond the
point of shine is becoming world
champion because uh so far all the sagas
I've stopped at the moment where our
protagonist reaches the title of uh
world champion so I'm still deciding on
that if you want to chip in on that
you're welcome to do so in the comments
but just to let you know you know
nothing happened to the standard Saga it
is coming but the the materials I'm
using they're just so so vast there's so
much information in it and uh I have to
sort it out properly for you guys to be
able to to enjoy it even more uh so uh
so yeah uh I just wanted to uh clear
that out uh and now getting to this game
let's check it out Ilia newsnik has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
we have pawned to C5 as advertised Hans
goes for the Sicilian Defense Knight of
three Knight the C6 and now Pawn to D4
uh the open Sicilian captures capture
Sunday for Knight to F6 and not Knight
the C3 and here we have Pawn to E5 this
is the Pelican variation of the Sicilian
or the seveshnikov variation or or the
Alaska variation depending on how old
you are you probably have a different
name for this uh variation because it uh
the trends change so Knight D to B5 we
have Pawn to D6 and now Bishop to G5
again very very standard stuff I will
point out however
if you are a bullet player let's say or
a hyper bullet player I often use a
trick in this position because you just
win pretty much every game uh to let's
say maybe to about 23 2400 even uh you
can try this very sneaky Bishop to E3
move it's not a good move because it's
very easily countered a black will play
A6 because it is the strongest move in
the position you want to get rid of this
Knight but now you don't touch the
Knight you just play Knights to D5 and
uh very often your opponents will just
play eight captures on B6 and now a
capture some B5 and now they can resign
Bishop to B6 attacks the queen and black
really doesn't have a move here if you
play Queen D7 just Knight the C7
checking E7 you pick up the rook and you
are completely winning and if your
opponent is a bit more resilient
um after this Knight the D5 move uh for
example a captures Bishop to B6 check
they might try Bishop G4 to attack your
queen but it doesn't matter just F3 and
yes okay now the queen is guarding the
Rook but the bishop is hanging so it's
pretty much the same thing Queen C8 the
Knight Will ever check your king E7
Knight captures Queen captures and now
you will just finish the line by
capturing the bishop again in a
completely winning position the problem
why you don't want to play this in a
slower time formats maybe you can even
pull it off in a three minute Blitz game
I don't know depending on how strong
your opponent is uh point is that after
this A6 move Knights the D5 uh black can
just play Knight captures on D5 and in
bullet it will probably work because
your opponent will see that after he
captures on D5 his Knight and C6 will
also be hanging so he might try
something else he might pick up the
Knight on B5 but if your opponent really
wants to refute this they will just
capture and after Pawn captures they
will capture on B5 you will capture on
C6 they will capture here and the black
just has a massive Center here that
black will enjoy for the rest of the
game let's say c3d5 and the black has
all the control uh this will be very
very hard to play with white so it's fun
if you want to win uh you know some
quick rating points and if you played uh
the Sicilian if your opponent goes for
for the Pelican variation you can try it
I mean okay but these are very strong
players they go for the main lines
Bishop to G5 they don't just blunder
games like this uh Ponte A6 Knights the
A3 and now Pawn to B5 we have Knights
the D5 and the bishop to E7 so again all
standard Theory nothing new here Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now the two
main moves here C3 and C4 uh yeah you
can play C4 it's perfectly fine then
black Advance is the pawn to B4 but C3
is considered more solid you just
stopped B4 and you cleared the E2 the C2
Square for United and then it comes the
E3 controls D5 controls F5 this is very
good for white
so Hans castles and Ilya goes Knight to
C2 we have rooked the B8 by Hans and now
Pawn to A4 of course a very standard
idea when black has um an advanced Pawn
structure on the queen side like this B
captures on A4 by Hans and now uh you
might expect something like root
captures on A4 but first Knight to B4
offers a trade of knights not the Knight
on C6 is hanging so knight uh Hans
trades Knight captures Knight captures
and now Bishop to B7 and okay white will
now regain some material Knight captures
on A6 Rook to A8 and now uh there is a
game where Rook captures on A4 was
played but it's a bad move because after
Bishop C6 you just have too much to
worry about the Rook is now stuck
guarding the the Knight here and also
the pawn on e4 okay the bishop still
guards the Knight but the queen can very
easily attack the Knight and you're just
gonna have problems here for example if
Rook B4 yes you want to keep defending
the pawn in Queen A5 and your position
is just disgusting you you can resign
this
so instead after Rook to A8 we have
Queen captures on A4 and it is now as of
move 17 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how Hans deals with
this now uh the move you always want to
look out for and you always want to look
forward to it when you're playing with
the black pieces in the Sicilian is Pawn
to D5 if it's possible to execute Pawn
to D5 then you should always do it and
this is exactly what Hans does now it
would be a bit too optimistic to play
Just e Captain D5 Queen captures because
then your G2 Pawn is
um not hanging okay but you can't really
develop the bishop you can't play G3 uh
the white king is stuck in the center
you can resign this with white so
instead we have Queen to B5 makes more
sense it puts pressure on the D5 Pawn
puts pressure on the bishop but Hans
plays the very very uh clean Queen to E7
and here he just says okay what do you
play here your king is still in the
center that's kind of the whole point of
this uh line because if he captures on
D5 Rook have to d8 and knife well what
do you play
uh the the D5 Pawn is saying there's
just not all that much you can do you
can try something like C4 but then just
Bishop captures an A6 I mean there's uh
too much stuff happening Happening Here
Bishop captures Rook captures and after
for example Rook captures Queen captures
uh there's Queen to B for check and now
you're not castling your king is just
dead lost here so what would probably
happen is you can offer a queen trade
but then Rook D6 and again there's
really no move here for white uh so
instead after Queen E7 Bishop D2 was
played and now Hans just plays Rook the
A7 still not rushing with a capture on
e4 he wants to double up on the a file
and again if a cat person D5 Rook after
A8 and uh the white will not be able to
withstand this so Rook the A3 now the
knight at least can move the pawn The
Rook on A3 is defended and now uh
finally Hans plays the captures on e4 we
have castles Here and Now Pawn to E3
opening of The Bishop's diagonal and uh
it's a it's a position that we often
face when we we when we play chess where
you know you can play F3 but you know
it's it's such an ugly move you really
don't want to play it here best for
black would be probably to either just
capture or even to go Knight to C5 and
then after let's say Rook captures B
captures e captures on F2 uh with check
Rook captures now your Bishop is hanging
you're gonna have to move the bishop now
white will play an id4 and the game
continues black has the bishop pair
which is spectacular as the white king
is a bit open here but white does have
the past A and C Pawn that he can use
however in the game Ponte F3 was played
and yeah like I said I mean we all play
this we all do this we we're like yeah
I've created a very very solid structure
here I I'm a great Builder but it simply
doesn't work uh so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find why it
doesn't work while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
lines of attack must be open towards the
white king and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn to E4
this is the only move that gains
Advantage for black because now there's
really no good way to meet this if you
push Pawn upon the pawn to F4 yes you
kind of immobilize black spawns here but
not just Bishop captures on A6 and if
real characters look at this Rook B7
going after the B2 Pawn you cannot stop
this queen T4 Rook captures on B2 and
it's just a terrible terrible position
for white so instead after E4 F captures
an E4 was played but now uh we see we
have the uh and also uh sorry I just
wanted to mention instead of the move
that was played F captures on e4 you
could try Queen to C5 it's a it's a very
very cool idea you offer a queen trade
uh and then we would see something like
e captures and F3 and then you cannot
really capture The Rook here if you
capture the Rook then F captures an E2
and you resign if rookie won just Queen
to E4 threatening Checkmate uh and if if
you play Rook captures to defend then
just Queen to B1 will be Checkmate as
the pawn covers the F2 Square rookie one
Queen captures will be Checkmate so what
you will have to do after he captures an
F3 probably G captures on F3 and now
Rook after A8 or something and it's
still uh very very hard to play this for
white maybe it doesn't lose by force but
it is very hard however in the game f
captures an E4 was played and now Hans
just gains all that Hans dreamed of for
the entire game Queen captures on e4 now
the Queen Bishop battery is very strong
and this diagonal and uh the only way to
basically stop this properly is to play
Bishop to F3 but even this does not work
just Queen the E7 and now we have Queen
to E2 sorry about that I think the
mailman just arrived
foreign
yes indeed it was the mailman it's like
it's like they know when I'm recording
uh but yeah uh Queen to E2 was played
and now just Bishop captures on F3 we
have Rook characters on F3 and now Rook
to E8 guarding the at the past Pawn here
we have Rook to A1 and now Queen to D6
preparing to drop the queen to D2 We
have Rook to F5 probably with the idea
of Shifting The Rook to A5 but uh it
could also also be some some other stuff
here so Queen to D2 offering a queen
trade and you can't really go for this
captures captures and now for example uh
there's already the threat of Rook
captures an A6 Rook captures and then
Pawn to D1 will just bring your queen
into the game and if Rook after F1 just
Rook uh Rook eat A8 attacks the Knight
and that's all there is so instead after
this queen to DT move we have King the
F1 sort of Defending but now just Rook
captures an A6 by Hans anyways in this
position and move to a 29 that
elianiznik resigned the game and Hans
gets his first victory in the Fortress
classic I think he started with some
seven draws in a row and then he wins
the game eight uh or maybe the game nine
uh I will check I don't want to trick
you guys let me just check real quickly
yeah this is this is uh round eight so
seven draws and then he wins the game uh
in round eight and here he resign
because if you capture The Rook for
example Rook captures on A6 then you no
longer control the the back Rank and
then just Queen C1 check the F2 square
is still covered Queen E1 E2 with check
King F2 and now Queen to E3 will be
Checkmate and if you don't do this if
you play Queen captures on A6 then EQ
would check King to G1 and E1 brings
another queen into the game Rook
captures on E1 and now Rook captures an
E1 with check Rook to F1 Rook captures
and F1 King captures on F1 and now Queen
to C1 with check and just to avoid any
back rank issues and snatch upon while
you're at it with Tempo King F2 Queen
captures on B2 checklist the king F1 and
now you can even play the boring Queen
ba just to stop Checkmate Buddha Queen
here defend the bishoplay G6 play King
G7 and you win the game
uh so yeah of course Ilya knows this
after Rook captures on A6 he resigned
and a very nice victory for Han smoke
and Neiman who is a again under live
rating list a 2700 player he's in fact
2700.00 so we'll see if he if he
continues the the upward Trend or will
he drop back to 26 90 something we'll
we'll see how it goes uh so yeah uh
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it
um uh very very nicely done by Hans it
was a quite an enjoyable game because I
really like this line the the swishnikov
or the last girl or the Pelican I've uh
some 15 years ago I uh studied some
theory on it with why because one of my
uh friends who was incredibly strong he
was like 22.50 at that time in classical
rating he he played this line with black
and I always got bashed with it so I had
to really really know the lines if I
wanted to survive against him in in
Blitz Games because we used to play like
uh 100 Blitz Games for sitting
uh so uh you know this line definitely
brings back some very very uh good
memories uh but yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it the line that
I've shown uh only use it uh in maybe
bullet and Hyper bullet or if your
opponent isn't too higher rated maybe
even in a three minute Blitz game but
don't try it uh any any uh you know
higher than that so yeah really hope you
enjoyed this I would like to thank
Marcus grabble uh James Chambers Bradley
Peterson Robert hovsepian and brown
Equity Bowen equity for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up any wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World while I'm uh
finishing up the preparations for The
steinit Saga so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day